oh
boy is this an exciting unboxing so the
lego super mario lego kits are
i honestly like a dream come true from
my childhood and i actually got to make
a dream video come true where i turned
my entire living room into a super mario
like of course like it's the coolest
thing ever if you guys missed that video
i'll put a link in the description but i
just wanted to quickly show you guys the
new luigi starter course you basically
need one of these starter courses but
then from there you can expand into all
of these expansion sets and there's so
many this is one that i was very excited
to check out this is bowser's airship
this is gonna be so fun to build and now
they've released luigi you can actually
team up for new adventures so you can
connect them together to play with a
friend
there's a pink yoshi in this starter
course
no way
oh
that makes me so happy
so cool
my favorite thing about these sets is
that it connects to an app so you do all
of your building there and it's cool
because it's all 3d so you can kind of
spin your little bricks around and you
can see where things are supposed to be
placed here's luigi's little body
oh there he is look at him look at him
look at him ah
it's so cool our battery is included
because
is this gonna fit in there yes
[Music]
ah lego luigi time here's his little
pants
his hat
his ears
his suspenders
he's all set look how cool
he got dizzy
okay lego luigi is super cool now let's
open up mario
[Music]
here he is
you look great mario
god i'm so excited about this like
honestly i oh it's gonna be so cool have
you seen the lego mario like the actual
lego sets well i've seen them online not
in person well guess what there is now a
player two and they have a lego luigi oh
no
so i already did the unboxing already
okay so here's the lego luigi
and here's lego mario and i love that
they like okay like luigi's a little bit
taller but like he's barely
barely he's taller i really appreciate
that it's just like a little bit more
but he is taller so i already started
this video
that's why they're they're
they're in these pre-packaged ziploc
bags this is going to be so much fun
because the best part about this is you
can actually link this to an app and you
know how like old-school lego sets like
you used to have to actually use like
the paper instructions
you link this up now to the app and you
can go through like step by step and you
build
the sets virtually and this entire lego
mario universe is really expansive like
there's tons of sets but to do all of it
you have to have the starter pack
and this is it this is it this is the
starter okay
and what's so great about this app like
check this out we just like
go through
and it'll give you all of the pieces
digitally like look how much this is
awesome easier this is okay oh this
makes it a lot easier so much easier so
there's these little qr type code things
here which are really cool because this
is how
mario and luigi know
like what enemy this is so this symbol
yeah it just scans it so check this out
oh
and you get coins
i know
so now we need to put the pipe together
oh i did this wrong it's okay okay then
green okay here we go
[Music]
he's tired it's motion activated too so
like it'll it can tell like whenever you
move it and stuff there are so many
different steps so this is the flag and
i think we just jam that in there
let me just snap the flag on
so we have our start and end so here is
showing you kind of like how to do it so
they've got a little connector thing
here so this is kind of a super basic
course so we're going to start with this
look they have little flowers you can
make little flowers oh my gosh i want to
make one yeah this is cool oh my gosh
these are so cute
okay
oh where do i put them um you can put
them wherever really
okay now this is the real demo okay
start
i love it and it's got the music and
everything
i love them
it's so great okay check this out so now
we're gonna be opening up let's see
number three three it blows my mind how
far legos have come from when i was
growing up
to now
i messed up
oh oh oh oh
there we go okay fix it fix it fix it
did it i just can't wait until you see
like how cool the courses are they're so
excited look they're they're partying
over here they're like yay
they are set
okay next up we're gonna be making pink
yoshi yay
this might be my favorite okay so do you
have their eyes
a lizard a dragon
it comes out of an egg
i see a dinosaur a dinosaur or some kind
of a reptile i've never thought about
what yoshi is i think he's a dinosaur i
you know he's probably make believe wait
i put the eyes on i don't think i was
supposed to do that yet
no yoshi has a lot of parts she does
have a lot of parts and then we put
yoshi body
so yoshi is all put together now it's
great because all the stuff like
obviously works together
coinbox
[Music]
are you awake
it's so great okay so there's still more
to put together so let's finish setting
this up and then we'll get our course
all ready here that's nice all right all
right
cool we've got all these little
connector pieces oh
okay so we can do like one of these
so now this is kind of fun i love it so
you can make your own course
any way you want it and what's neat is
this little contraption here will allow
you to like go like this so you can
collect points when he's on here look at
this does it do this
but it spins maybe let's switch this
okay to like is this little small one so
that i can put that here and connect
how's that look over there there that i
mean that's really cute
so the cool thing is when this first
came out there was only mario but now
with the addition of to the luigi set
like you can actually sync these all
together so there's a bunch of different
things you can do when you go into the
two players so you can connect them
together you can move them together you
can defeat enemies together and then you
can just do like the different platforms
and it's so cool because you can
actually play with two people here's our
start pipe okay so i'm gonna go through
the course and as soon as we hit the
start it's gonna put 60 seconds on luigi
and mario's clock and then you collect
as many coins as possible okay i'm gonna
go first and then after i run the course
then you can go with mario and we can
see who's okay okay
[Music]
and then he's gonna fly over here
basically you just kind of want to like
tap on it a lot so you can get a lot of
coins
and then look it shows up on the app oh
yeah
so i only got 15 coins but this shows
you everything that i ended up getting
go for where is that go
big boy point blank result
oh snap whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh
you're running out of time
oh wow you got 35 coins oh that's
incredible i love this another cool
thing which we didn't even show you yet
is this there's different outfits that
you can put on mario and luigi to change
kind of like their whole little like not
only their look but how they interact
with things this is the bee
you think he's gonna make a new look
i wouldn't say that cool fireball outfit
you know they do
yes it's white and red yes i almost
brought that one but i thought it might
be a little aggressive well that's it we
put it together they have so many more
sets that this is honestly just the
beginning i want to do a whole room of
this i want to do a whole like we could
make a whole video game we could because
every level you have so many different
sets and you only need the start and the
finish and you can build everything in
between it's so so so so cool we might
need some friends to help us put these
sets together well ro thank you so much
for building with me this was so much
fun thank you for bringing these over
this blew my mind literally smart legos
justine shows me smart tech all the time
with i already said coffee mugs gadgets
but now legos it's so so so cool well
thank you so much for building and thank
you guys for watching make sure you go
check out ro's channel we have done so
many fun videos on hers and i'm so glad
that there's now a player too
yeah now we can play together will you
be my player too will you be my player
you'll be my player one no no you're
like one i mess that up we can i will be
your players
[Music]